[Música]
continúan los homenajes al príncipe
felipe duque de edimburgo las banderas
de los lugares emblemáticos de londres y
otros edificios ondearon a media asta el
cuerpo del esposo de la reina isabel
segunda permanecerá en el castillo de
windsor lugar donde falleció hasta que
se celebre su funeral en la capilla de
sant words tenemos reporte desde el
hombres
jair bolsonaro se declaró víctima de
activismo político después de que la
corte suprema aprobara la creación de
una comisión para investigar la
respuesta del gobierno a la pandemia el
país ya roza las 350.000 muertes por su
parte argentina y chile- registran
cifras récord de contagios a pesar de
las medidas de contención y la
vacunación
y a un día del super domingo electoral
en américa latina' de ecuador se
encuentra dividido en la segunda vuelta
de las presidenciales en perú los
ciudadanos se escogerán entre 18
candidatos al nuevo presidente y bolivia
elige a 4 gobernadores en el balotaje
les contamos cómo está el panorama
electoral en estos tres países
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si raúl algo como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en reino unido donde continúan los
homenajes al príncipe felipe duque de
edimburgo quien falleció ayer 9 de abril
a los 99 años de edad muchos de los
británicos están de luto por la muerte
del príncipe y otros ciudadanos da una
visión más matizada condenando algunos
de sus comentarios que calificaron de
racistas y consideran que la familia
real es parte de otra época los detalles
del funeral aún no se han dado a conocer
[Música]
los londinenses siguen depositando
flores y haciendo homenajes a las
afueras del palacio de bukingham tras el
fallecimiento del príncipe felipe pero
nada ha sido como en las últimas décadas
cuando murieron otros miembros de la
realeza y no porque los británicos
sientan menos cariño por el duque de
edimburgo sino porque la familia real ha
instado al público a evitar
aglomeraciones debido al cob y 19 aún
así muchos presentaron sus respetos
hemos venido a llorar con la reina y
todos y sabemos que no hay nadie más
triste que la reina eso lo sabemos y
sabemos que la reina tomo sus manos
mientras él se iba con dios
lo hemos perdido un gran hombre y él ha
dado tanto por lo que se merece los
tributos mucho mucho más tributo de lo
que realmente le estamos dando pero no
todo el mundo está devastado por la
muerte del príncipe felipe quien tenía
99 años y cuya salud había empeorado
recientemente su monarquía hachemí no
soy monárquico la muerte del príncipe
felipe si bien puede ser una tragedia
para su familia no tiene sentido en mi
vida
may-bowles a medida que la sociedad hace
una introspección en las cuestiones del
racismo entre las personas en la prensa
y dentro de la familia real algunos
recordaron las
versia sobre antiguos comentarios hechos
por el príncipe
algunos de ellos han tenido un tono un
poco más racista lo que es menos
perdonable pero creo que todo eso debe
equilibrarse con la visión general de
los oakland debido al cove' 19 se está
revisando la organización del funeral ya
que actualmente sólo 30 personas pueden
asistir a estas ceremonias es probable
que se limite a familiares cercanos se
dice que el propio príncipe quería un
funeral discreto vamos precisamente
hasta londres donde se encuentra nuestra
corresponsal luisa pulido ella está a
las afueras del palacio de buckingham
donde a esta hora varias personas se
encuentran depositando flores en honor
al duque luisa muy buen día como es el
ambiente hasta ahora
buenos días ya se han escuchado 41
cañonazos durante 41 minutos en todas
las naciones del reino unido en
gibraltar y en los buques británicos en
altamar para honrar la memoria del duque
de edimburgo para celebrar su vida su
rol en la familia real y también para
homenajear ese papel tan importante que
tuvo dentro de la monarquía de ser el
soporte la roca de la reina isabel aquí
en las afueras del palacio de buckingham
siguen como mencionas acercándose
miembros del público a presentar sus
condolencias a la familia real en
especial a la reina a quienes resaltan
ha perdido a su amado esposo se respira
un ambiente de mucho respeto siguen
acercándose cada vez más integrantes del
público la familia real les ha pedido
que no lo hagan que no vengan a este
lugar ni tampoco dejen flores a las
afueras del castillo de windsor donde
murió ayer el duque de edimburgo por las
actuales restricciones del confinamiento
que hagan donaciones de flores de
recursos a algunas de las 800
organizaciones de caridad de las que el
duque de edimburgo fue su patrón ese es
el ambiente que se respira a esta hora
aquí en las afueras del palacio como
ustedes pueden ver a mi espalda cada vez
siguen y siguen llegando más miembros
del público luisa le pregunto ahora
cuáles son los detalles que se conocen
en el funeral del príncipe
no se han ultimado esta es una decisión
de la reina isabel que será comunicada
se espera en las próximas horas lo que
se sabe es que el duque de edimburgo
quería un funeral sencillo más de
carácter militar recordemos que él tuvo
un papel muy importante una carrera muy
exitosa en los años 50 como piloto y
también durante la segunda guerra
mundial así que su corazón está mucho
más cerca de las fuerzas militares
quiere un funeral lo quería un funeral
en el que las fuerzas militares fueran
protagonistas así que se sabe que será
además privado e incluso se habla que
por las estrictas normas del
confinamiento que vive en inglaterra en
el que a partir de este lunes no más de
30 personas pueden reunirse para un
funeral ni siquiera la familia real
completa podría reunirse para dar el
último adiós al duque de edimburgo así
que esa es la situación se espera que
los próximos horas en los próximos
minutos la familia real la propia reina
isabel esté anunciando a través de un
comunicado cuáles serán esos detalles se
cree que el funeral
será en ocho días lo hizo también le
quiero preguntar por último cómo está la
seguridad en la zona y también si se
sabe algo de los príncipes del príncipe
harry contará también esta polémica de
su esposa megan marcos y también del
príncipe william
claro la seguridad por supuesto está
ahora en las afueras del bac y no para
las es enorme hay gran presencia
policial incluso afuera de las rejas del
palacio de máquinas no sé si ustedes
alcanzan a observarlo hay seguridad
privada y también hay una especie de
fila para que las personas puedan entrar
organizadamente a dejar las flores se
dice que el príncipe harry quien está en
medio de la polémica por esa entrevista
que dio con su esposa megan markel en la
que denunció que ella no se le
atendieron requerimientos de problemas
de salud mental y también de anuncios de
racismo podría venir aquí al reino
unido- usando su pasaporte diplomático
para poder estar con su abuelo se dice
que el príncipe harry era el nieto
favorito del duque de edimburgo luisa
gracias por toda la información por
supuesto muy pendientes a lo que ocurra
en londres con este funeral que se va a
llevar a cabo el príncipe
belfast registró su octava noche de
disturbios aunque de menor intensidad
que días pasados los manifestantes en
irlanda del norte se enfrentaron con
bombas molotov y piedras a la policía
antidisturbios la violencia comenzó el
pasado 29 de marzo en las zonas
protestantes unionistas pero en los
últimos días se extendió a varios
católicos nacionalistas al funeral de un
ex miembro del ira revivió las
rivalidades entre los partidos y también
los efectos a largo plazo que tiene la
salida de reino unido de la unión
europea una sensación de traición entre
unionistas por este acuerdo este
estallido de violencia se da cuando hoy
se conmemora en 23 años del acuerdo de
viernes santo
francia marcó un nuevo récord diario de
vacunaciones con 500 de 1000 personas
inoculadas así lo anunció el ministro de
sanidad
oliver vegan ya hay más de 10.5 millones
de personas que han recibido al menos
una dosis un 15.7 por ciento de la
población total francesa el ministro
estuvo el viernes en la inauguración de
un vacuno dromo en la ciudad de grenoble
y este sábado se abre otro en la de sant
etienne en los hospitales el número de
enfermos o por coronavirus disminuyó
ligeramente por segundo día consecutivo
pero creció el de los pacientes en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos
en américa latina brasil registró tres
mil seiscientos noventa y tres muertes
por koi 19 este viernes esta mañana el
país sudamericano ha superado dos veces
la barrera a los 4.000 muertos en 24
horas consecuencia una brutal oleada que
tiene desbordados a los hospitales por
su parte el presidente ya el bolsón aro
arremetió contra la decisión del
tribunal supremo que ordenó la creación
de una comisión de investigación para
averiguar presuntas omisiones del
ejecutivo en el manejo de la crisis
sanitaria en argentina y chile- la
situación tampoco es favorable así nos
lo explica albert bayot
brasil sigue enfrentándose al oscuro
panorama de una crisis sanitaria sin
precedentes una de cada cuatro muertes
por kobe 19 en el mundo esta semana se
registró en el gigante sudamericano que
ya roza los 350 mil muertos por la
enfermedad y aún no hay luz al final del
túnel
el ministerio no tiene una varita mágica
para resolver todos los problemas y
estamos trabajando todos los días para
llevar alternativas a la gente de brasil
el presidente y ayer bolsonaro se dijo
víctima de activismo judicial después de
que un juez de la corte suprema ordenara
la instalación de una comisión en el
senado para investigar su manejo de la
pandemia argentina también registró este
viernes un nuevo récord histórico de
contagios por corey 19 superando los
24.000 positivos en 24 horas esto cuando
el mismo ya entró en vigor un paquete de
medidas restrictivas que incluyen toques
de queda nocturnos y límites en las
reuniones sociales medidas que regirán
durante tres semanas pero que dadas las
dificultades económicas encuentran
detractores del corazón de su economía
cerrado
de nuevo con el año que viene
chile también tuvo récords más de 9.000
contagios en 24 horas por primera vez en
toda la pandemia evidentemente que esta
cifra de más de 9.000 casos es
preocupante
pero nosotros estamos haciendo todos los
esfuerzos posibles para evitar que se
siga propagando el virus y además dar la
atención de salud necesaria para
cualquier persona para cualquier
compatriota para cualquier habitante de
chile que lo necesite por ahora ni una
cuarentena más del 83 por ciento de la
población ni una campaña de vacunación
rápida que ya llega a más de 7 millones
de chilenos han logrado frenar el virus
y seguimos en américa latina la región
andina celebra mañana el super domingo
electoral con tres países llamando a sus
ciudadanos a las urnas un dividido
ecuador decide a su mandatario en la
segunda vuelta electoral en perú lejos
de tener un futuro decidido 18
candidatos se debaten la primera vuelta
a la presidencia y en bolivia los
izquierdistas del más buscan revalidar
su vuelta al poder a través de las
regionales veamos al informe que ha
preparado marina sardina
en la víspera del super domingo
electoral andino tres países de américa
latina celebran este domingo sus
llamados a las urnas a la sombra de la
pandemia de kobe 19 ecuador se encuentra
fracturado en la segunda vuelta de los
comicios los ecuatorianos deben decidir
entre el neoliberalismo de guillermo
lasso o el retorno al socialismo de
andrés araujo el candidato al correísmo
para suceder al presidente lenin moreno
ambos prometen la superación de la grave
crisis económica de una nación con
fuertes divisiones políticas ideológicas
y sociales donde el / voto indígena que
representa entre el 7 y el 10 por ciento
del censo nacional puede ser la llave
del triunfo electoral a mí me gusta las
elecciones para nombrar un mejor ecuador
tener algo pero una elección que se
anuncia muy indecisa y el preludio de ir
a la segunda vuelta en los comicios más
abiertos de la historia en un país donde
el carisma el candidato prevalece sobre
las ideologías 18 candidatos
presidenciales debate en la primera
jornada electoral peruana con 6
liderando las encuestas pero sin que
ninguno supere el 13 por ciento de
intención de voto para resolver la
inestabilidad institucional crónica
económica y la emergencia sanitaria en
medio de un desencanto generalizado con
la clase política peruana
el fujimorismo está aprovechando la
ventana de oportunidad pero los
escándalos de corrupción de su líder
keiko fujimori genera el rechazo entre
el electorado
se puede analizar a su salud
candidatos
bolivia elige los gobernadores en
segunda vuelta en cuatro de sus nueve
departamentos donde el movimiento al
socialismo del ex presidente evo morales
busca el control de las principales
gobernaciones para hacerse con la
soberanía de la mayor parte del país
adicional al ejecutivo que ostenta a su
aliado luis arte
y de américa latina' cambiamos de
continente nos vamos hasta hacia 69 días
después del golpe militar en myanmar aún
no se avisora una solución y el país se
va al filo de una guerra o una
revolución al menos diez policías
perdieron la vida este sábado en el
noroeste del país durante un ataque
coordinado de varias guerrillas étnicas
que a finales de marzo se lanzaron un
ultimátum ultimátum a la junta militar
por la brutal represión contra las
manifestaciones en rechazo del golpe de
estado militar del primero de febrero
argumentaron que si la junta no detiene
las acciones violentas y no satisface
las demandas de la población
participarán con los manifestantes en
las protestas de la llamada revolución
de la primavera como ya lo vemos
entonces en este ataque aunque aún
todavía no se han reivindicado estos
ataques ninguna de estas guerrillas
hasta que el informativo contiene con
nosotros
[Música]
frente